yeah there's a toaster dude David
Patrick Neal he snuck in apparently he
was casing The Joint the day before
because he was trying to like change out
the TV or help the guest with the TV
okay and then the guy was woke up with
him in his room and he said Oh I thought
I smoked
yeah I didn't know that yeah Brandon
reportedly screamed when he found out
Neil sucking I'm not into this yo yo
this guy got issues if you had
to do pervert you know it's funny that
man let him suck his toes you know
ain't no way I'm a I'mma wait mid suck
you know what I mean like I'm
like I'm and I'm gonna feel someone
sucking my toes there's no way you wake
up three minutes into a toe stuck he was
getting so sucked he liked it he thought
that that dude was snitch and he was
like oh he's the gay one 100